i was talking to uh steve now wiki about
eddie van halen khan i thought like um
there's an eddie van halen con it's all
eddie van halen's super fans and guitar
builders and you know he's a guitar
builder he built his own it was
unbelievable i mean it was just like the
most amazing day of being around
all these eddie van halen fans everybody
had the 5150 replicas out there we
compared the dents the relics we talked
about the wood that was used on it we
debated where some of the dents were
from 1983 some of the dents were from
the kramer factory when they built them
on the 5150 i brought my 1984 body i was
showing that it was oh it was unreal was
your 5150 replica
of eddie van halen's famous guitar the
best one there because you're pretty
detail-oriented or
there it is
yeah there's parts of it that were the
best but
the main thing that threw me on because
this is some people relic them in the
modern day style this is relic to look
as close as i could get it to the 1986
5150 tour so the way it looks on the
back to this but the main thing i
noticed is the the grain so this is a
guitar is made of basswood which is the
main theory on what the wood they used
so the grain i i did this fake grain
cutaway but i went a little i went about
a half inch too far with it
so i've learned that the grain is not
right but everything else is pretty
solid the relic is pretty solid and
and all that what is the end game with
all this steve do you hope to morph into
eddie van halen at some point maybe do a
tribute show i mean what are we working
toward here you know it is a thing that
like it's a good skill where i now know
how to repair guitars i can do the paint
jobs well but i'm also like building
guitars i really know how to do
you know repairs and all that stuff so i
mean it's a legit skill to have too he
can repair guitars if things fall
through here i mean
work in the back room at guitar center
would it be possible if all you dudes
got together all you guys who know how
to build these guitars and just build an
actual eddie van halen like a robot that
could
could play like eddie van halen
um
by the way
not only is steve a complete maniac for
everything eddie van halen but i should
congratulate him i congratulated him
this morning he's engaged
and this guy was a big problem
look at this
i kept messing with her and around eddie
van gaal and con i kept saying you
should come to connecticut i'm like i
might want to ask you something at eddie
van gaal and con and she was like if you
do that to me i would she's like that
wouldn't be good just don't do it i said
i was gonna propose at evh con and then
play panama just but i wouldn't have
really done that i was just [ __ ] with
her the other big news out of eddie van
halen con was steve got to hold the
actual drill
that eddie van halen used
when he looked just like the drill that
i built too it was one of these
the makita drills and it was the one
from the
the 95 tour that he he does the pound
cake on which is the song that's like
[Music]
you